thank you Yasser Alex first of all
welcome back and congratulations this is
a great start for you as the defending
Champion ah thank you very much yeah
that was an interesting game and uh
Douglas is the first time he's a rookie
on this tournament and he didn't change
his opening very much last 50 years so
do you know him uh well have you guys
played against each other a few times no
I think you stopped playing chess before
I came to the states I mean uh actively
I mean of course if he was playing all
these times and uh
and uh but seriously I Was preparing uh
using his games back in 80s wow yeah wow
so he's still playing the same opening
it's a goalie and uh I think
maybe Queenie 2 was technically the
first novel yeah that I like did not
look pretty I mean queen F3 not here
okay Queen the heroes queen of three
um
yeah so here 22 Yeah that's the move
that I didn't realize specifically
analyze but everything before going to
F3 on the board something else yeah yeah
I think in this line if white wants
something he shouldn't Castle too early
because that's uh and what's the plan
behind that's a critical critical loss
of time powder uh same same he did like
Queen F3 and all the kind of things the
same thing but without cast but don't
Castle because that's it and now I need
to go like
uh but might not on this summer and it
has to be on C6
perhaps you have some C4 ideas or
something like that is is that why but
it's not a position from again
oh yes yeah that night was on C6
so something like that yeah Knight needs
to go to C6 so he can go to B4 and to E7
and
so people
yeah sometimes white plays A3 sometimes
he doesn't but at least that's uh that's
an interesting happier yeah and then at
some point perhaps you will go long
Castle or nobody did yes like no not
really yeah but he did short castle and
it does seem like there's quite some
games in even uh Anton giharo versus box
so some some strong players have played
this position before uh I think it was
all interesting and Knight F5 was good I
believe a B7 I played too fast I I
should have started with Rook C7
so in case of Rook C1 I have Queen E7
and A3 suddenly it's hanging yeah that's
that was the bishop takes a three ideas
right I think that was a little bit
incorrect on my part and then position
just became like really complicated oh
yes Knight F1 the strong move hit took
on C5 I come
took me by something I said and C4
um probably what I felt like white
should be slightly better because pieces
standing really well so I played yeah
Knight E4 takes takes here using B7 yeah
here came the critical moment so I kind
of knew that Knight D4 might not be the
strongest move in the position but
if I play Rook d8 yeah here
then
I probably missing a chance to activate
my Bishops and so sooner or later
eventually I will have to play Rook D3
and suck anyway exact something so I
thought like I'd rather do it earlier
than when I still have time yeah so
Knight D4 might as well get it over with
this yeah but objectively I I felt like
it shouldn't be that great
yeah and I think this move uh Knight to
G4 instead of E4 just so that it doesn't
hang potentially the S35 was better for
him yeah that that looks pretty uh
dangerous but then again first round
yeah better take a risk now of course
why why not you have to yeah yeah 94 and
actually you mentioned even before the
tournament that it's not the preparation
it's more about the resilience those
later rounds physical preparation was
that something that you emphasized in
your training yeah specifically for this
tournament if uh so last year I played
non-stop prior to disarming my eye this
time I decided to take like a complete
break and just do physicals instead and
we'll see how it goes you're feeling
good entering the tournament but it's
such a blood blast today
yeah it's going to be quite a race I
Gotta Feeling oh okay that's that's good
well it was last year as well you guys
ended up in a five
yeah that's true so um and I I yeah I
think I made a mistake
yeah F1 for eight point that was
completely unnecessary he should have
195 it seems like 95 yeah or Rook D4 on
a previous move no maybe not now it's
like um right maybe here before yeah I
thought
probably slightly better for me but not
that much yet still with black pieces a
great start for you Alex congratulations
guys any questions for our defending
Champion absolutely first of all welcome
back to St Louis uh Chevy
a reunion it feels like a reunion does
it feel like a reunion for you you see
all of these guys that you've known no
absolutely yeah it's a Pity just once a
year yeah right yeah we need more
serious
yeah there should be a Christmas
tournament The Summer's tournament
exactly like four times five times a
year that's that looks like appropriate
number yeah you can get the answer to
play in them yeah of course yeah
congratulations and uh yeah well eight
more games to go it's gonna be a race
yeah thanks absolutely